[Música]
bueno hoy quiero comenzar con un hecho y
con una pregunta el hecho es que la
demanda de energía mundial está
creciendo exponencialmente
la pregunta que les quiero hacer hoy es
qué características creerían ustedes que
ha de tener una fuente de energía ideal
para suplir esta demanda
este es el national estiércol toros
experiment
en este ex localizada en el laboratorio
de física de plasmas en la universidad
de princeton donde yo vengo
esta parte de acá que está brillando
está próximamente a 10.000 grados
centígrados y es la parte más fría
esta parte acá adentro donde está
invisible está aproximadamente a 15
millones de grados como la temperatura
del centro del sol esto es un reactor de
fusión nuclear y mi intención hoy es
convencerlos que la energía de fusión
nuclear será una parte esencial de la
solución a este reto de energía que nos
viene
esta es la esta gráfica muestra la
demanda el consumo de energía de varios
países a través de los últimos años
vemos acá arriba los mismos de siempre
eeuu la unión europea consumiendo muy a
muy altos niveles pero por lo menos
relativamente constante acá abajo aquí
aquí bien pegaditos al piso estamos
colombia por lo menos no somos una gran
parte de este problema no quiero que nos
enfoquemos en estas dos curvas
esta roja que está creciendo
exponencialmente es el consumo de la
china y este crecimiento está altamente
correlacionado con el desarrollo
económico de este país o sea esto es
positivo esto es esto es bienestar de
muchas personas pero en términos de
energía es complicado
esta es la india la verde y esta es la
que más me preocupa porque todos los
modelos sugieren que esta curva también
va a tener este mismo este mismo tipo de
crecimiento a medida que la economía de
la india se vaya desarrollando entonces
en este momento que fuentes están
sufriendo esta demanda
por la gran mayoría son hidrocarburos 67
por ciento y esto es carbón
esto es gas natural petróleo esta es
relativamente fácil de adquirir y muy
fácil de quemar pero como todos ustedes
saben es un genera mucha polución y
genera gases que contribuyen con el
calentamiento global o sea queremos un
futuro donde minimicemos esto a su
máxima o mínima expresión
27 por ciento son hidroeléctricas
y fisión nuclear lo que coloquialmente
llamamos energía nuclear la gran mayoría
de la energía de colombia son de
hidroeléctricas y ya estando construidas
es una energía prácticamente inagotable
pero bueno lo pongo entre comillas
porque con el cambio global de
temperaturas uno nunca sabe qué va a
pasar con estos ríos
estando pero pero crear estas estas
estas fuentes de energía requiere
repensar ríos y esto tiene consecuencias
ambientales y sociopolíticas y además
necesita estar al lado un río
entonces depende altamente de la
localización nuclear es muy eficiente
pero el combustible es difícil de
adquirir el plutonio el uranio
hay que saber tratar con los desechos de
largo plazo radioactivos y siempre está
la posibilidad de un accidente
catastrófica entonces éste también es
tiene tienes un nivel problemático
el 6 por ciento es lo que uno como
sociedad quiere estar desarrollando las
renovables pero aún estos tienen sus
problemas
se requieren muchísimas hectáreas de
paneles solares o de aerogeneradores
para suplir la demanda una acrópolis en
otras palabras está esta fuente energía
es de baja densidad de energía estás
mirando esto podemos volver a la
pregunta con la que pensé que yo les
propongo las siguientes características
de una fuente ideal de energía ha de ser
abundante inagotable el cielo ha de ser
limpia que no genere polución que no
contribuya con el calentamiento global
ha de ser segura que no tenga una
posibilidad de un accidente catastrófico
ha de ser eficiente que se genere mucha
energía al ser geográficamente
independiente de que brille el sol de
que sople el viento de que estamos
regresando un río que se pueda conseguir
en cualquier parte finalmente que sea de
alta densidad que con una planta podamos
darle la energía a una ciudad pues vengo
aquí a contarles que esto existe y
sorpresa es fusión la energía de fusión
tiene todas estas características por
eso es que científicos hemos estado
tratando de desarrollar esta tecnología
durante décadas
bueno pero que es fusión
pues la fusión es la razón por la cual
todos existimos y nuestro exagera
no solamente es la fuente energía del
centro de todas las estrellas incluyendo
la nuestra sino que es responsable de la
creación de todos los elementos más
pesados que el hidrógeno como el carbono
como el oxígeno como el nitrógeno todo
lo que nos deja vivir
todo eso fue creado por fusión en centro
de estrellas incluyendo los supernovas
pero eso traté de x
entonces que es en verdad que como
ocurre la función función ocurre cuando
dos átomos pequeños son los núcleos de
los átomos pequeños se juntan creando un
átomo más grande y si uno pudiera [ __ ]
una balanza y pesar el antes y el
después nos daríamos cuenta que se ha
perdido un poquitico de más
kiko de más pero esta masa se ha
convertido en energía a través de la
famosa fórmula es igual a en ese
cuadrado es la energía que estamos
tratando de sacar ahora un paréntesis
fisión la que coloquialmente llamamos
nuclear es el procede es el otro lado de
la moneda cuando núcleos grandes se
dividen también generando energía de
esta misma manera
bueno entonces esta es fusión en el
centro del sol hay muchísimo hidrógeno
que está constantemente fusionando sí
pero esto duran millones de años este
proceso en el sol dura millones de años
pero pues el sol no tiene afán y tiene
gravedad que mantiene todo el hidrógeno
y todos los productos en su lugar
nosotros si tenemos aparte de nosotros
necesitamos utilizar otra reacción
diferente diferente a la del sol pues
utilizamos otro tipo de hidrógeno dos
tipos de hidrógeno el deuterio y el pib
ahora el deuterio es el deuterio es
fácil de adquirir en la tierra es
bastante abundante de muchos de los
hached osos del océano son en verdad hd
y entonces hacemos el mismo proceso
sacamos del deuterio y tenemos para
millones de años de reactores de fusión
y el tritio es otro cuento no existe
naturalmente
pero lo podemos sacar del litio podemos
crear tritio a través del litio y el
litio si es bastante abundante es la
materia prima principal de la batería de
los celulares que tienen las manos
porque acaba de sonar
la batería del computador y esto es muy
abundante en este momento se saca de las
minas pero lo podemos sacar de los
océanos y si somos suficientemente
eficientes podemos pretender ya podemos
sacar suficiente tritio también para
millones de años de fusión o sea fusión
la materia prima de fusión es
prácticamente inagotable para nosotros
los humanos
también es muy eficiente
para comparar voy a mirar la demanda de
una ciudad mediana como cartagena la
demanda en una ciudad mediana se puede
suplir con una planta de aproximadamente
un gigavatio de energía
este es el estándar de potencia entonces
cuánto combustible necesitamos para un
año de una planta un viva vatio si lo
hacemos de carbón si lo hacemos de
fusión entonces si lo hacemos de carbón
necesitamos una mano de vagones llenos
de tren llenos de carbón si entonces
necesito que me ayuden a contar cuántos
vagones deben más de uno
25 a 100
400 más que 400 mil 600 no 6400 una más
30.000 vagones de carbón pero acá hay
como 25 mil 600 pero me cansé de hacer
cuadrados 30 mil vagones de carbón se
requiere para para cartagena por un año
si quiero hacer esta planta de fusión
necesito llenar una camioneta llena de
deuterio y tritio les podría contar pero
solamente una
una camioneta estas reacciones son
millones de veces más eficientes que los
hidrocarburos bueno y miremos la
reacción de auterio + tritio genera en
el genera energía en forma de un neutrón
muy muy veloz y cuál es el desecho helio
helio el de estos dos y es más es tan
eficiente esta reacción que para el
helio para este lo que para él el helio
para el desecho de para crear la energía
para una familia como hay cuatro
personas durante 12 meses es escasamente
suficiente para llenar este globo
y además como sabemos si me funciona
no
en el yo es inerte
[Aplausos]
en el yo no contribuyen con el
calentamiento global
la energía de fusión es limpias porque
más de un poquito energía fusión el link
bueno pero hay un problema de otero y
tritio se requiere muy altas energías se
acuerdan que no estamos utilizando lo
mismo del sol esta es más poderosa pero
requiere que la temperatura sea mucho
más caliente que la del centro del sol
desde hace aproximadamente 10 veces más
caliente 150 millones de grados sentidos
entonces este momento es también pueden
estar diciendo arturo pero este ridículo
eso nunca va a funcionar nunca vamos a
poder llegar a estas condiciones en un
laboratorio pues
nosotros digamos constantemente estas
condiciones en laboratorios a través de
todo el mundo no solamente en el mío
sino también en este tema y en nuestros
sonidos en japón en la república checa
hasta en costa rica hasta hace poquito
empezó este reactor en costa rica
a través de todo el mundo llegamos a las
condiciones de fusión pero nunca hemos
llegado a un punto donde se genere más
energía de fusión que la energía que se
requiere para correr una de estas
máquinas
hasta ahora
este es y te que significa el camino en
latín y es un experimento que se está
construyendo en estos momentos en el sur
de francia y el lado colaboración de
todos estos países representando más de
mitad de la población mundial con
referencia a mira que un francés
este experimento es uno de los más
complejos en la historia a la humanidad
y uno de los más caros en este momento
se estima que está costando como 25 mil
millones de dólares pero la primera vez
que vamos a mostrar experimentalmente
que se puede generar más energía de
fusión que la energía que se requiere
para recorrer la planta para correr la
planta pero esto no es y eso será por
ahí en unos 10 años pero no es
suficiente porque no hemos generado
electricidad
el siguiente paso es poder absorber toda
esta energía de fusión que sale más o
menos en calor y calentar a agua o
calentar algún gas y darle vueltas a
turbinas para generar electricidad estas
plantas generadores eléctricos de
electricidad se estima que estarán
dándole electricidad a la red eléctrica
aproximadamente como en 30 años
30 años será como 100 años después del
comienzo de esta aventura
la investigación de fusión comenzó
después de la segunda guerra mundial
cuando científicos buscaron utilizar la
energía del núcleo
no para destruir sino para como lo
utiliza el sol para dar vida
y así como la revolución de fabricación
de herramientas o la revolución agrícola
o la revolución industrial fueron
momentos en la historia donde la
tecnología permitió que nosotros como
humanidad creciéramos exponencialmente
la energía de fusión traerá una nueva
era donde el crecimiento exponencial no
va a ser de población sino de la calidad
de vida para billones de habitantes sin
destruir nuestro planeta muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]